[Aplausos]
la escritora sudafricana angie croc
cuenta que conoció en senegal a un poeta
nómada del desierto que le explicó la
función de los poetas en su cultura la
labor del poeta le dijo consiste en
recordar dónde están los pozos de agua
potable
la supervivencia de su grupo depende de
esos escasos pozos de agua potable que
se encuentran diseminados por todo el
desierto cuando el pueblo se olvida
dónde está el agua es el poeta el que
los puede conducir hacia ella
esta metáfora me parece muy acertada
para pensar el rol la función de los
artistas en una cultura
pero por qué no también
para pensar el rol de cualquier
ciudadano comprometido en su sociedad
cuáles son nuestros pozos de agua
potable
si el teatro fuera un verbo ese verbo
sería recordado esto lo dijo una
directora de teatro norteamericana hace
bastante tiempo recordar del latín
récord es volver a pasar por el corazón
esta etimología que nos la recordó
eduardo galeano en su libro de los
abrazos recordad
mi abuelo quedó ciego cuando yo era muy
chiquito mi primer vínculo con la
lectura en voz alta fue leer para él
le leía principalmente el diario por las
mañanas
de ley a los titulares y cuando algún
titular le interesaba me pedía que lo
desarrolle
a mí me gustaba mucho la parte de la
sección de deportes y ahí el pícaro me
hacía desarrollar mucho pero me pedía
algo que era mucho más interesante para
mí me pedía que le describiera las fotos
y esa tarea me encantaba de escribir los
personajes las miradas los colores
con el tiempo como todo niño me empecé a
aburrir me aburrí a leerle el diario a
mi abuelo ciego entonces cuando llegaba
a las fotos empezaba a imaginar cosas
que no estaban le hablaba del fuera de
cuadro de la foto le inventaba
personajes obviamente él se daba cuenta
era imposible que hillmán cabeceara un
centro en el clásico entre rosario
central sin él son luís y un transformer
lo atajara imposible pero él me dejaba
seguir lo disfrutaba lo disfrutaba
muchísimo hicimos con mi abuelo un pacto
un pacto de imaginadores un pacto de
fingidores
nabókov decía que no leemos con la
cabeza
tampoco leemos con el corazón
leemos con la espalda más precisamente
con ese lugar entre los dos como platos
donde alguna vez tuvimos salas
creo que ahí comenzó mi vínculo con el
teatro
con mi abuelo la capacidad de imaginar y
hacer que el otro imaginé con voz el
teatro es el reino de la imaginación y
ese legado me lo dejó mi abuelo
mi abuelo murió muy poco tiempo después
de esta foto él no supo nunca el camino
que su nieto iba a recorrer no lo supo
pero tal vez lo imagino
el arte tiene un compromiso inevitable
con la imaginación con la capacidad de
todos los seres humanos para inventar
para reinventar libremente para soñar
para ampliar la realidad la imaginación
no es un ejercicio de gente desconectada
con la realidad que vive en el aire que
está volada no no no todo lo contrario
cuando imaginamos lo hacemos
condicionados por la falta de algo
concreto por ejemplo cuando un niño
imagina una escuela alegre y libre lo
hace justamente porque su escuela le
debe estar negando la libertad y la
alegría
la imaginación es el nervio de la vida
nos permite pensar que podemos
organizarnos a futuro de otra manera que
hay otros modelos de sociedad que
nosotros mismos podemos cambiar que
podemos proyectar ciudades a futuro
militar causas defender derechos una
ciudad que imagina es mucho más rica en
la crítica y mucho más permeable al
debate
mi imaginación es el nervio de la vida y
su opuesto es el fatalismo el fatalismo
hace que nos quedemos anclados en la
queja porque es nada puede cambiar todo
está mal pero nosotros tenemos la verdad
no existen las preguntas sino las
respuestas el fatalismo no nos lo
podemos permitir
hace poco vi una película taiwanesa de
tres horas
se los recomiendo de vez en cuando hace
falta ver películas taiwanesas de tres
horas se llama jiji
ahora van todos a ver tres obras de
edward yang en ella uno de los
protagonistas es un niño de ocho de ocho
años el padre le regaló una pequeña
cámara de fotos y el niño está toda la
película sacando fotos pero les saca
fotos a las nucas saca fotos de nucas y
las revela y tiene decenas de fotos de
nunca su tío un día el tío lo viene a
visitar el tío está triste porque el tío
está preocupado por las finanzas él
quiere ser rico quiere dinero dinero no
lo consigue y se pone triste y el niño
se le acerca y le regalé una foto el tío
la agarra y dice que se esto que esta
porquería una nunca una nunca quema la
foto se ríe ridículamente burlada mente
y el niño hago las espéculas taiwanesas
el niño con una sabiduría increíble le
dice tío
es para ayudarte a ver esa parte tuya
que no podés ver
la imaginación que nos ayuda a ver esa
parte que no podemos ver
es mi primer pozo de agua o tal
ese es mi papá arquitecto intentando
trabajar
el otro está aburrido
y lo molesta con desafíos imaginarios yo
no me acuerdo cuál de los dos lo propuso
pero por ejemplo yo le decía papá papá
papá se casa un gato con una paloma que
sale
y mi papel estaba obligado a pensar una
fauna fantástica a partir de la
provocación su imaginario era provocado
por dos elementos que aparentemente no
tienen vínculo entre sí y mi padre no
tenía otro remedio que pensar en la
hipótesis de un gato mensajero
y algo en ese chispazo empezaba a
moverse papá papá se casó una bicicleta
con una escalera que sale
la scj atleta dijo y que es la ex atleta
y es una bicicleta con ruedas cuadradas
que para subir escaleras
papá papá se casó una gallina con un
elefante que sale el gallifante y cómo
es y es chiquito pero es muy pesado y
qué forma tiene y tiene forma de gallina
pero con trompa
no papá si tienen forma de expresiones
chiquitas si tiene trompa cómo va a
caminar se va a caer para adelante
es el único animal del mundo hijo que
por tener dos patitas y trompa se
desplazan dos patitas trompas dos
pasitos trompas y porque es pesado
porque pone huevo de marfil
[Música]
no no no puede poner huevos marfil papel
marfil es duro cómo van a salir los
pollitos de adentro
viste alguna vez algún elefante
por eso hay pocos hijos porque salen los
más bravos no más hay que ser gravísimo
para poder romper el huevo de marfil y
ahí seguíamos no les relato más pero
esto no paraba no paraba y lo que
hacíamos con mi papá me parece para mí
una definición que yo quiero mucho de
creatividad la capacidad de relacionar
dos elementos que antes no han sido
relacionados y la pauta que los conecta
es el creador me gusta mucho esta
definición de creatividad porque se
emparenta directamente con la poesía
cuando le preguntaron al gran poeta
español federico garcía lorca que es la
poesía el hijo es la unión de dos
palabras que supusimos nunca se iban a
encontrar pero lo hicieron y al hacerlo
dejaron encerrado un misterio
fíjense el parecido de la definición y
obviamente este parentesco entre la
creatividad y la poesía se cierra con un
primo cercano que es el humor porque la
risa es un reflejo del lujo que tenemos
que da cuenta de un auto creativo por
momentos recién en mi relato algunos se
reían porque porque ese chispazo produce
esta risa que no sabemos muy bien para
qué sirve y si sirve para dar cuenta de
que ahí se produjo un acto creativo así
como la risa da cuenta del acto creativo
del humor
la emoción da cuenta del acto creativo
poético emily dickinson dijo si tenéis
la sensación física de que se te vuela
la tapa de los sesos eso es poesía es
una definición maravillosa hace poco me
vino a visitar un amigo se acaba de
separar cuando te viene a visitar un
amigo mano al hombro y le digo esa
pregunta tremenda cómo estás y me dice
atentos estoy más maltratado que revista
de peluquería
así hablamos en córdoba y yo me reí
obviamente un momento duro y yo me reí
porque porque él en esta forma
metafórica que tenemos de hablar los
cordobeses cruzó elementos que no tenían
que ser cruzados en ese momento una
separación del dolor y yo recordé las
vieron las las revistas en la peluquería
no este mismo amigo cuando se había
puesto de novio tiempo atrás me vino a
visitar yo le puse el hermano al hombro
y le dije cómo estás y me dijo tengo el
corazón arremangado como funda de salame
hay que tener estos amigos es como las
películas taiwanesa se los recomiendo
pero para llegar a la creatividad
necesitamos el aburrimiento que yo le
doy mucha importancia a la noción de
aburrirse
es muy importante aburrirse saben que la
palabra aburrimiento fue inventada por
unos monjes en el es un invento cultural
de occidente en el siglo 4 después de
cristo al principio lo llamaron demonio
del mediodía
parece que los monjes del monasterio
almorzaban llegaba la siesta se metían
en el cuarto y que sello no se les daba
como que tenían un alejamiento de lo
sagrado para ir a ese territorio profano
y a eso lo llamaron o no aburrimiento
vienes por mí
horror en sentir horror es la etimología
aburrimiento sentir horror pánico al
vacío hoy varios muchos no me van a
decir le veo aburrirse pánico no capaz
que la definición varía pero es muy
importante el aburrimiento para poder
llegar
como es importante el silencio para ir a
la palabra o la quietud para ir al
movimiento o la oscuridad para ir a la
luz o el vacío para ir al matambre que
no se come vacío a los lleno y se me
cruzaron los cables la creatividad es
muy importante tengo una sobrina de 8
años que se llama josefina que es divina
para mi oráculo yo le pregunto todo a
ella y el otro día le pregunté josefina
que es el presente
la película taiwanesa te quema en el
cerebro igual los niños les hace
preguntas complicadas que es el presente
josefina y ella no se achicó y me dijo
es como tu cabeza piensa de verdad por
ejemplo las bufandas son serpientes
buenas
y me regaló el título para una obra de
teatro el más bello que alguien pudiera
regalarme las bufandas son serpientes
buenas
mi segundo pozos de agua potable es la
creatividad
el teatro es un arte político al menos
por tres razones primero porque es el
arte de la crítica y la utopía segundo
porque se realiza en asamblea como aquí
y tercero y el más importante de todos
porque su firma es colectiva el teatro
necesita al menos de dos personas para
existir
este es un colectivo de personas acá
faltan tres más porque somos seis
hermanos estamos ahí en una especie de
picnic al lado de la ruta y aparece mi
madre al fin aparecen las mujeres mi
madre
la que me decía cuando era chico hijo no
salgas por el calzoncillo roto porque
podés tener un accidente y yo decía
porque le preocupa más mi ropa interior
que me piso en auto que es mucho más
complicado o también me decía no me
revolví en los ojos que soy tu madre esa
me encantaba mi madre porque aparece mi
madre porque dicen que el término amor
etimológicamente viene de un sonido amar
con dos gm que se usaba para llamar a la
madre que varón o la etimología de amor
incluya la figura de la madre mi mamá y
mi papá
deliraron veían películas taiwanesas me
parece y dijeron que teníamos que salir
a recorrer todos nuestro país seis hijos
y decidieron que saliéramos a recorrer
todo el país lo dividieron en zonas nos
subieron a una especie catramina que
pudo hizo mi papá con colchones y allá
fuimos y ese colectivo conoció toda todo
el país toda su toda su cultura todas
sus gentes todos sus paisajes ese legado
increíble que me dejaron estos dos
locales los cachés totales y los pero lo
más importante de este recuerdo volver a
pasar por el corazón cerebro es que en
ese viaje yo recuerdo la solidaridad de
la gente el amor ante cada obstáculo una
vez en un viaje se nos pinchó la goma 15
veces 15 veces se le pinchó la habana el
papá un problema y nos ayudaban la
solidaridad la colaboración lo colectivo
está muy vinculado a eso por eso mi
tercer y último pozo de agua potable es
el amor
palabra del amor de que nos va a hablar
porque me interesa el amor porque el
amor es una construcción o al menos a mí
me gusta pensarla como una construcción
colectiva donde al menos tiene que haber
un 2 y que se sostiene a partir de la
diferencia en el amor tenemos que
aceptar que la experiencia del otro pasa
a ser nuestra preocupación el amor
necesita de una confianza absoluta en el
otro es inevitable en esa cuestión
colectiva que avancemos amorosamente ya
lo dijo el gran poeta rimbaud hay que
reinventar el amor ya se sabe en el
libro de darwin el origen del hombre
la frase la supervivencia del más apto
sale dos veces y la palabra amor sale 95
veces y en cada interpretación histórica
que hemos hecho del libro siempre hemos
reforzado la idea de que sobrevive el
más apto
y no hemos reforzado la segunda noción
cuál es la naturaleza del hombre
cooperar colaborar o dominar si somos
animales que nos entregamos al
salvajismo de la competencia pero
también somos animales altruistas que
podemos trabajar cooperativamente y
colectivamente
eso que estaba ahí era lo más parecido
que hay para mí el teatro mis seis
hermanos los seis juntos abrazados
porque porque el teatro
es un lugar donde nos encontramos
como aquí respiramos juntos nos miramos
nos escuchamos gracias
creamos juntos examinamos cómo vivimos e
imaginamos otras formas de vivir nos
aburrimos porque no debatimos nos
complementamos como esas películas de
piratas donde había un mapa del tesoro y
cada uno tenía una parte y hasta que nos
juntáramos todos no íbamos a encontrar
el tesoro esa experiencia colectiva
solidaria cooperativa es el teatro y son
estos 6 pitufos locos
cuáles son sus pozos de agua potable
cuáles son esos pozos que deben guardar
en la memoria para que su comunidad su
grupo su sociedad su pueblo su ciudad
no se pierda pueda sobrevivir pero
también pueda proyectarse a futuro de
manera más amorosa cuáles son nuestros
pozos de agua potable
muchas gracias
[Música]